malgré leurs bons jours merci d'être
avec nous je suis mail vous avez dit
hier soir vous aviez fait de modeste de
progrès la voix est toujours bloquée
quand est ce que la voix cesse d'être
bloqué massification à régler
certainement
hier on a eu l'occasion pour une
première fois de pouvoir discuter
ouvertement des enjeux qui interpellent
les gens qui sont proférées à date ce
que j'ai pu réaliser puisque nous
auraient ils ont tous ces cons et aller
2-0 à rhétorique sans fard diallo y est
donc la question que je me pose après
des discussions d'hier c'est que oui il
ya une crise nationale qui a un impact
significatif sur l'économie
makam en réglant nous c'est un jeu comme
canadien on a le vécu de il ya trente
ans où les gens sont rentrés ils
apprécient rentrée un mort une crise
l'armee rentrée une personne qui
pratiqué le droit pendant tant d'années
juriste de formation l'état doit
mettrait cherché aussi j'étais aussi de
former comme cela d'infanterie alors je
sais pertinemment ce qui arrive quand
les choses vont mal
la question tout mais je pose comme
canadien qu'on devrait tous se poser
comme canadien c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
fait comme nation ce qu'on préconise la
voie de la paix d'ouverture du dialogue
ou ce qu'ont fait les réserves les
leviers à faire que qui nous ont menés
jusqu'ici puis qui ne cesseront jamais
alors j'ai choisi la voie d'appels
d'ouverture de la coopération et ces
gens là sont très créatifs parce qu'ils
sont à se sont fait rouler par le passé
mais il reste encore que les
protestations qui sont là et il reste
dans notre niveau au travers en même
temps il ya de plus en plus de pression
de l'entreprise privée des canadiens en
général qu'ils disent oui on a besoin de
cette voie là ce qui est pour moi y est
d'atteindre un premier temps vous vous
donnez vous dans votre tête en dire
écoutons les préoccupations des
autochtones mais en même temps les sont
les biens les services les personnes
circulait sur cette voie lactée moi ce
que je me dis c'est que faisons de
maintenir notre mieux de régler la
situation d'une façon paisible et puis
les gens qui sont là préconise la voie
de la paix c'est clair que y ait un
impact significatif sur l'économie
c'est quelque chose qui traient
interpellant nous sommes présentement en
discussion avec le cabinet du premier
ministre pour choisir la voie à prendre
moi je préconise de le voir la paix de
la coopération d'ouverture hier c'est le
dialogue qui a été décrit comme étant
historique mais qui somme toute est un
dialogue d'ouverture de discussions et
de direct baiser pour savoir ce que sont
les revendications pour savoir la fin de
vie ces gens là et le progrès oui
modeste mais les voies de communication
sur votre ouverte et on le sait tous
qu'en les voies de communication se
ferme
c'est là où ça barde mais sans mini
dialogue sans mines il progresse qu'un
moyen pour vous de mettre un terme au
blocage et de poursuivre le dialogue
tout le monde combien temps c'est ce que
les gens la maison sur des consommateurs
premier temps ça va durer
ce qui est important de savoir pour les
canadiens c'est qu'on est ce qu on règle
ça comme du monde de façon paisible à
faire c'est ta façon dont se perçoit ni
même comme étant canadien où est ce
qu'on fait les vieilles affaires qui ont
marché et qui ont mené à 6,6 et donc moi
je préconise encore l'ouverture dialogue
coopération et j'espère j'ai beaucoup
d'espoir il reste encore qu'on a du
travail à faire en colombie-britannique
alors
nous allons dépêcher la ministre bennett
pour continuer ce dialogue et nous
allons mettre nos ressources pour
s'assurer que nous réglons ce ce conflit
de façon de façon pacifique mandalore ce
que j'entends c'est que ça exclut
l'intervention policière
les injonctions que le cn entre les
mains vous ne recommander pas qu'elle
soit appliquée vous tentez de garde vous
tenter de calmer les choses se calment
et la donne c'est ça mais l'effort de la
police selon un protocole d'engagements
discrétionnaire et des escales à sion 2
dans le jeu qui leur sont propres et
nous préconisons tous les moyens pour
s'assurer que nous réglons que ce
problème de façon pacifique pour
s'assurer que ne se reproduise plus
parce que force est de constater que ça
arrive à répétition et qu'on n'est pas
arrivé à régler sur cet enjeu de façon
sensée et faut qu'on fasse la bonne
affaire comme pays on est dans un pays
non réconcilier force est de constater
se fait alors quels sont les enjeux que
nous prenons faisons-nous la façon dont
on veut bien pour s'assurer que nous
avons c'est de bell aliant son bel
esprit de coopération
ou est-ce qu'on rêve est ce qu ont fait
les affaires qui ne marche pas le coeur
le point de départ du problème c'est
c'est le projet de gazoduc qu'un colon
britannique la compagnie avait
l'impression d'avoir l'aval des
premières nations sur le tracé du
gazoduc est ce qu'il ya une erreur est
ce qu'on a mal fait le travail la bresse
qu'on a mal compris les peuples
autochtones
quand est venu le temps de la voir une
projet ça fait plusieurs chèques qu'on
comprend mal les gens je sais que là bas
il est clair que l'aval de certaines
communautés des communautés où elle
souhaitait
des conseils de bande et lui il y aussi
un enjeu profond de droit héréditaire
comptes au titre sur lequel passe ce
gazoduc
c'est un enjeu qui relie mais quitte
aussi distinctes de l'enjeu de
l'environnement et du gazoduc donc il ya
deux concepts parallèle qui existent en
même temps en finale c'est une question
qui doit se régler ensemble avec une
discussion franche et ouverte avec les
représentants héréditaire des eaux si
j'ose croire à clé les représentants
élus de façon communautaire avec lang
l'engagement du la province de la
colombie-britannique et aussi du canada
vous avez dit hier je dois je dois
tourner au premier ministre je retourne
au cabinet vous mentionniez tout à
l'heure il ya des options sur l'atelier
d'histoire qu'on va devoir faire quels
sont ses choix que vous avez devant vous
à l'heure actuelle pour tenter de régler
la question ainsi que là il faut avoir
une certaine avancée en colombie
britannique les autres choix qui auquel
saint nazaire suspendre le projet
d'année il faut continuer l'engagement
pacifique ans que l'on me britten et
qu'il est les enjeux que j'ai partagée
avec le premier ministre hier vont
rester confidentielle très évidemment
pour ce qui c'est un enjeu très sensible
qui veut rester dans l'enceinte du
cabinet pour l'instant quitte à le
partager avec les canadiens en temps et
lieu qu'est ce que vous dites à ce
qu'ils disent je peux pas voyager j'ai
pas ma marchandise j'ai pas mon matériel
c'est assez dur et ça fait dix jours
maintenant
qu'est ce que vous leur dites contenu
fait pas d'échéancier pour l'ouverture
des lectures des mois je reçois des
courriers je reçois des appels de
beaucoup de gens beaucoup d'industries
qui sauf si clair que le canada en
entier sauf et des pénuries qui commence
à se manifester à travers les industries
c'est très intéressant parce que je me
demande aussi en tant que citoyen
canadien c'est comme en réglant nous
c'est un jeu très profond de notre
identité qui ne va pas disparaître du
jour au lendemain alors régler ce
problème
aujourd'hui et attendons pas demain
parce que la voie spécifique c'est la
voix qu'on préconise comme canadiens et
ça relève de notre identité nationale
mcmurray au ministre des services aux
autochtones version italienne